head coach Bruce Pearl here on the
program how are your coach I know you do
which is have to pause for a second and
go the Auburn Tigers are heading to the
Final Four it's kind of mind-boggling
okay so hold on let me do that again
now joining us on the program getting
set to take the Auburn Tigers to the
Final Four head coach Bruce Pearl that
is music to my ears I bet what is it
what would it mean to you to cut down
the nets Monday night
Wow just I think rich obviously great
for Auburn and and our fans and our
University and our kids and our staff I
think the other thing too would be for
all those division 2 coaches or guys
that have been assistants for a long
time that a mutt
a total mutt has a chance to to win it
all and and so I think for me that would
be that'd be be pretty cool what do you
call yourself a mutt coach I wasn't a
great player I had a career-ending knee
injuries when I was in high school and I
had to start off my college basketball
career as a manager at Boston College
and and just worked my way up and thank
God for Tom Davis and the confidence he
had in me and the things he saw in me
and and so I guess that's kind of we
start at the bottom and we're working
our way pretty close to the top dr. Tom
the longtime Iowa coach this is one who
he's the one who essentially gave me
that big first chance or did you who who
do you credit in that regard no rich it
was it was it was that it was coach
Davis at Boston College even before
Stanford in before then it was Iowa so
yeah back in the late 70s when I started
at Boston College yep and I know I look
a lot younger than that yeah I was I was
I was at BC when ESPN was born and you
were you know kind of getting started
and yes you know really going back in
the day so that's that that's what it
would mean for me that you know grateful
for the opportunity that Tom Davis gave
me and and if I can do it just about
anybody could Bruce Pearl here on the
Rich Eisen show
how how many times as Charles Barkley
called you during this tournament how
many how does that happen
as much as he's called me during the
regular season and no more you know he's
he's the real deal
100% authentic enjoying a run but I also
understand I need to work and and he he
registers the most important thing his
confidence level and me was never it was
never any different when I was growing
it and developing it and not winning
he still had great faith and it was very
consistent and and and now you know
obviously we're starting to enjoy some
of the fruits of that labor
Bruce Pearl here on the Rich Eisen show
what challenges does Virginia pose for
you on Saturday well you know it's all
about matchups and that's one of those
statements that doesn't get used enough
even though it's overused Virginia
values possessions offensively and
defensively meaning they make every
possession count they always get a good
shot they always have a so an offensive
possession they're efficient we play
faster we don't value possessions we
have more possessions because we shoot
it quicker and if you do get involved in
that too much you're going to get beat I
think that we're not going to change how
we play a lot but we've got to be able
to beat Virginia at their own game or in
a slower paced game because we're gonna
have a hard time making them go faster
we're gonna a hard time turning them
over so therefore we better value
possessions a little bit more well
obviously if you make your shots that's
the way you could try and keep this
thing up-tempo if you guys make your
shots and boy do you take threes I mean
you're second in attempts nationally
first in three-point makes it at what
point did you and again you know
obviously we talked about the evolution
of your career it seems that the the the
premium of threes that we've seen in the
NBA where the three is a better that a
better shot than a two has has taken
over basketball what point did you
become an acolyte for something like
that long long long time ago I mean long
long time ago it's just that look you
listen what you just said when the three
became more valuable than stew or
whatever the word you just use just well
that's not rocket science I wasn't a
math major okay but I mean an inside
three-point shot foul and one is the
best offensive play in basketball all
right the second best play is the open
three-point shot and everybody makes a
big deal about a free throw the fact
that it's free and that there is no
contact and nobody listen if you can get
an open shot from you know six feet
behind the free-throw line or whatever
it is and it's and whether it's
contestant art there is no contact and
you can't shoot it at 40% you need to be
doing something else and and so you know
I just we've always believed in that and
and so we try to do things to get open
shots now we played Kentucky in the
regional final and Cal did a phenomenal
job of not letting us get open looks and
not getting us many free shot we'd only
made seven threes but we were able to
then take what they were able to give us
and that is some favorable matchups one
on one we've got to the rim enough and
we actually beat them with two point
basket so you've got to be able to do to
be able to do both so then I guess the
worst shot in basketball is a two-point
shot just inside the three-point arc in
your question there's no question you
listen you hit the nail on the head in
the sense that like what do we work for
defensively we work like crazy to get
people to take contested tough to plunge
shots that's what we get so why would
you then offensively try to create a
scheme that gives you contested
two-point shots doesn't make any sense
so what do you say to a kid that that
hoists a two from 18 feet out pretty
much random winner made it per missed it
okay Bruce Pearl here on the Rich Eisen
show
so obviously Auburn making the Final
Four is something to celebrate Duke just
missing it is something people are
responding to that there's seasons of
failure how do you how do you take that
concept and yeah it's a great great
comment
all right so the seasons are failure a
number one seat an appearance in the
Elite Eight sweet 16
what they lose four or five games all
year long how in the world can that be a
failure I understand that expectations
are different at Duke our expectations
are different in Kentucky but that
doesn't mean just because the
expectations might be different doesn't
make it a a success or not a success
look there are let's just say we say at
the big Internet legitimate ly 25 teams
capable winning a national championship
and so and I think that's safe to say
and so therefore if 25 teams are again
not the math major if you're expecting
that one team of those two teams to do
it mathematically that's just not a
reasonable expectation and so you know
Duke got beat by a great Michigan State
team and a great coach and it came down
to what last possessions so so if the
kid makes two free throws not just one
all of a sudden that that makes you know
my sous-chefs key the genius that he is
again or because he missed a free throw
he's no longer the genius that he is and
we've got to be we've got a I understand
about bottom lines but there are two
teams that are out there trying a couple
more questions for Bruce Pearl Auburn
head coach have you decided what you're
gonna say to the kids before the game
Saturday do you know now what's your
process on that subject matter yeah I
don't know I mean we talked about
passion poison purpose we talked about
playing with passion and playing hard we
talked about being poised and probably
heal in the moment the environment and
then our purpose is to try to win two
more games that's that's the end result
but the whole focus is the process the
things we need to do to try to have a
chance to beat Virginia strengths
weaknesses gameplan just say it over and
over again be repetitive you know I
think that would be would be probably
what my moment whether it's gonna be
like okay I won't really know till we
get there but so you
when you walk in the door you just feel
the moment and just go for it there's
nothing prepared for a big no-no rich
rich I will every game it's the same
it's the same routine I'll put the line
up on the board I'll put my game plan up
on the board right there for the players
to hear and I'll go through it with them
step by step here's how we're covering
this here's what you need to take away
here here the play calls that I like and
here's why I go through it it's the same
when we're playing an exhibition game
preseason or playing for a chance to
play for the national championship it
will not be any different I will be no
more intense
I will not sweat less or more I will not
have any different facial expressions it
will be the same are you aware that
there are some that are interested as to
whether you have an extra shirt on hand
because you sweat through a shirt in a
big game where you wear that there are
those who focus on things like that
yeah with hard-earned American dollars
I'm hoping for some sort of a deodorant
contract or some kind of a perspiration
deal and I won't get it because I'm
going to continue to sweat so therefore
you know they're beginning is starting
to make these shirts that don't that
prevent you from perspiring nothing if
they could ever get oh yeah if they
could ever get me in one of those now
we're talking about something now we're
talking
now we're talking does anybody last one
four does anybody in the state of
Alabama use the verge fits in terms of
that oh yeah yeah we have several guys
on my staff that use it and then
understand it okay no it's not exactly a
minion and I don't think there are many
people in Alabama to understand that
word but I think lots of them would
understand Fitz and I walk around the
south end Shalom y'all yeah all the well
I guess to bring it all full circle then
much knockos to you Bruce Pearl on your
on your journey to the Final Four and
let's chat along the line again you got
ads Bruce Pearl everybody right there
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience